Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a vaccine related voicemail.
This is a new conspiracy that vaccinated people
are shedding vaccine.
And if you spend time with a vaccinated person,
you might feel sick because they are vaccinated.
This is wild.
Listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hi, David.
My name is Ashley.
I'm currently 18 weeks pregnant and congrats.
Vaccinated with both doses of my science by
the vaccine.
Very happy about that.
But what I actually want to talk about today
is something I've noticed spreading in anti-tax
groups.
I am not an anti boxer, but I have seen this
because my cousin's wife is a hardcore anti
boxer.
It is this insane notion that vaccinated individuals,
they believe, are getting their vaccinated
immunity.
I don't know what they think it is.
Yeah.
To unvaccinated people standing nearby up
to the point where it is causing unvaccinated
people to have menstrual irregularities, heart
problems.
They're basically blaming any medical new
thing that happens to them on vaccinated people.
Speaker 1: This is exactly what they're doing.
So remember, at first, many of them were saying
the vaccine causes problems for the vaccinated
person, affects menstrual cycle, all this
other stuff.
Now, many of them have moved on to I don't
want to be near a vaccinated person because
just it's emanating from their body.
They never say, are you breathing it out?
Is it coming out of your eyes?
It's coming out of your ears.
Is your skin releasing it or is it coming
out of your body odor?
They never say, but they're claiming people
are shedding vaccine and it's making people
around them feel sick.
And I read about one employer.
I forget what this is.
Some small business said if you get vaccinated,
you will not be allowed to come to work because
vaccinated people are shedding vaccine and
making other sick.
I'm almost positive that that's against the
law to say you will be fired if you are vaccinated.
But this is getting really crazy and this
is the latest front in the anti vaccine nonsense.
It is wild times, but glad you were able to
get vaccinated.
Very, very good.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about Wisconsin Republicans killing
the Medicaid expansion.
We'll talk about the latest with my pillow.
And we will talk about an interesting hypothesis
about what Jeff Bezos is up to with Donald
Trump's apprentice tapes.
OK, all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show.
Get that bonus show my friends sign up at
join Pakman dot com.